or OSHA fear and I have had we've had a
deep [ __ ] path long and storied
history yeah and you know I'm gonna say
this right now there was a point in my
life where looking at me you're saying
I'm saying right now I'm gonna do I'm
gonna look at you know okay
it was a point of my [ __ ] life you
know I swear to god I hated you more
than I hated anyone else cuz you killed
off Freddie so I was next
Freddie Soto yeah you know he didn't
like me that money mostly ignored you
yeah he ignored me but I it was a
different let me say this yeah
you can bring up Freddie soda if you
want to what you did right but all those
[ __ ] the darkness from my past it's
all resolved itself hey man so good
Eleanor yeah
Eleonora Karen what's her last name
Kerrigan character Karen Karen Ken right
no character was friends with a comic
named Freddie Soto who was my favorites
he won the best comics in the country
yeah he he died but Eleanor [ __ ]
hated me what do you do what do you guys
doing he thought it was blocking the
camera are you guys doing man secret
codes oh yeah yeah so what I'm saying is
is that that's result itself yeah
you and I have resolved it solved
resolved yeah but um I want to hear it
from the very beginning well how we met
everything I used to host the open mics
at the Comedy Store
yeah but if that's when I met you no cuz
when I started Oh Shaq was hosting you
were just there he was the guy who was
like hanging out with it because you
would just finished being an employee
right so you were still like related to
the employees yeah I was a employee at
the Comedy Store I was a open mic her
essentially I had nothing going on
really I had nothing going on right
Carlos started taking the road a little
bit ride Mencia started taking me on the
road a little bit and then I met Arie
but you were younger than me yeah are
you working at the store - yeah I got a
job there
you got a done really quick I think I
did three open mics and then I was like
I just out of josie's or get a job not
to draw a hat
yeah and him and I became friends I
think instantly probably right yeah you
took care of this some of the younger
guys who really it was like
yeah I did then again say it again you
gave some tips on like hey man when you
ask the crowd if they've seen a movie
you just sit there waiting I think this
is your advice like I think we're like
Star Wars like I see Star Wars and no
one clapped you're like why are you
waiting you're gonna do that anyway just
say alright yeah yeah I've seen Star
Wars but and then go into it go anything
like it was you um was Morgan Murphy
ahead of the puppy later on she's like
she never play there but Nick Youssef
Taylor Taylor all those guys yeah yeah
you guys we forgot because they fade it
away they're probably my best friend
I've no idea they are yeah yeah what joy
marmo joy mark yeah but stop it yeah but
why Rick rumor Mike Ricca mm-hmm yeah
that's redundant but then we became
friends and then um what happened so
then I got mad TV you got my TV we went
down to San Diego together right you
borrowed a bunch of I can bring up
[ __ ] right you but you borrowed a
bunch of money for pills yeah well you
do we ever go to brothels together yes
in Mexico to watch bands will you see
you and I went to Adelina yeah you told
me you're like hey tip him I'm like what
you're like yeah it's gonna be 72 just
just give him 100 to put it on the table
like then they'll know to work harder no
I'm a smart guy and I'm crafty yeah and
I think things through and the thing is
is also you tip the guide that cleans
the room because he's got the worst job
in the world
interpreter jobs you know that show
dirty job the Tijuana jizz cleaner for
one buck yeah the worst job in the world
because it's separate two bucks is what
you get is you pay 60 for the girl yeah
which I know how much to give enough
that got to the third pip 11 for the
room yeah one for the jizz cleaner yeah
and he he was grateful for it like it
wasn't like you know here's a dollar he
was like oh that's it he was like grass
yet
like hey man I'm gonna clean up jizz
anyway now I'll get paid for it there
was this guy that I worked with at the
Brockton build this restaurant and he is
his dad had something to do with the KFC
chain like he was high up he had a lot
of money this guy but he also was
waiting tables with me this kid he was a
fat kid and he would get like three
girls right Anna and not have sex but
just eat their buttholes that's
something only a rich kid would do it's
like a money to work yeah you should you
should even kiss them I know it alone
eat butthole yeah and he was a guy that
was I was like it's just one of those
guys that like he went to Nam he didn't
but he had that jaded vibe about him
Araya like he just went to Nam right but
that was a seedy place so you and I went
there and then I got mad TV and then I I
got sober I went to rehab yeah you
brought me over yeah you got almost or
not about TV they made you go to rehab
made me go to rehab and then I called
you one night when I was at that place
uh-huh and I was living in LA and I go
I'm leaving you you need to drive to San
Diego to pick me up yeah first was like
you pick me I was like oh okay I like to
in the Moors
yeah okay where did the two girls come
after that in the hotel room the two
girls was the weekend we went at Elena's
the suit girls of what regrets at least
we stopped into the spot at the PB brew
house yeah there was a car that was like
an open-mike at the PB brew house no
nobody was a show okay yeah you got me
on yeah and we were gonna do La Joya the
next day well I was Wednesday in a
little bit of the Hawaii of the next day
right and while I was on you were
talking to these two girls yeah one real
hot and one just gross
yeah yeah and I know you're like that i
bombed yeah and you were like hey Ari we
had these two girls like this him I said
you're like no okay cool
if they didn't see that chance
yeah first were like oh we're meeting
guys and you're like well just sit here
you know how Bobby does it yeah yeah
yeah and then uh and then after a wild
like I guess we don't the meet the guys
and we'll hang out with you I didn't say
hey come back come back with us yeah I
did a story about this actually come
back with us and you're like okay but
they like we gotta move our bikes and
then we got back to our bikes and bikes
were stolen oh yeah crying yeah yeah so
crying about it don't cry and then
Bobby's like how much were they like
mine was 400 it was 200 and goes here so
let me just say something right now all
right
only good people do [ __ ] like that no
one gives up for Bobby like Bobby right
so then what happened so I give them
money yeah to pay for the [ __ ] bikes
yeah Sears went right back no they're
gonna buy a new Schwinn or whatever they
you know ever the hot bike they got they
got the runners on the side of the
handle bars but the [ __ ] bro can't bite
that hard yeah I don't know what to do
put him in the cage now you're growing a
cage [ __ ] yeah yeah why don't
you bite him like you bought me that was
[ __ ] that was even playful oh yeah Oh
Bobby's gonna eat you what year was all
this happening this was 2000 I don't
know - ish oh yeah he called me one day
and he said hey we're going to San Diego
and I was like okay what does I need you
to drive and I'm like why do you need me
to drive he goes I been up for 36 hours
on pills so I need to sleep so I have my
girl to drive he goes you can use my car
but I can't do it so we also got stuck
in [ __ ]
who's supposed to take is like two hours
ago they took us like 12 hours again I
remember that gonna piss in water
bottles I told you we said we were on
the highway stop dead stop there like
this arrest up there go get a snack stop
for two hours you've been we with 30
meters in two hours yeah just run across
the highway and get it yeah
we fought over a payday yeah yeah yeah
yeah did we finish the girl part so then
we go to PV and then we go so we don't
out with the hotel that I'm at now is
that's a grand colonial hotel nice it's
a really nice hotel - right two beds two
beds really nice oh yeah yeah and always
this happens to me right I pay for the
[ __ ] bikes you got the hot girl and I
got the hot girl who doesn't want to
touch me and the ugly one wants to [ __ ]
Ari yeah she doesn't get a lot of guys
yeah yeah so now I'm in a closet there
are researchers scripts right with the
[ __ ] hot one oh yeah so I'm trying on
each other's bits like he's on his bed
I'm on my bed with my girl he's gonna
sit that you're his girl and I'm we're
like making out as I've never done day
like this I've had sex with like three
or four girls at the time maybe four
yeah maybe five because he looked really
Julie back then yeah yeah yeah right he
looks good I do you look better now you
were younger it was like door beaker
yeah it's like you look weird yeah yeah
so we're taking I hear on the other
better shoulder yeah and so I'm trying
not to laugh don't play that game
oh I knew that I knew that my girl
didn't want to [ __ ] me
yeah or do anything with me but I know
that he was about to get some action and
it's weird we're both in the same room
we're in the same room so I'm like I'm
the closet wisconsin's the size of this
room yeah yeah it's like Oprah shoe I
was in it and I being the good person
even though and I'm also paying for the
room yeah I went coming to give my
friend a layup and I'm gonna go in the
[ __ ] closet
what did you tell her to get her in a
closet get in the [ __ ] closet no he's
like let's go in here you put all the
blankets he's like let's go hang out in
the closet yeah yeah yeah I was gonna do
like a Cambodian like attack sex attack
yeah put them in a little hole you know
I mean no pop or pot action
women in clothes room you know the
lights off and then
yeah after a bit we left we drove him
back went to Denny's and Bobby's like
you're paying for Jennings my paying for
daddies and he's like cuz I don't have
any money times you got late night it
and I was like I didn't get laid and he
goes I know you did I did not and then
he's like let's go back to her more show
you something yeah yeah yeah and he
showed me in the closet there's a vent a
ventilation grate yeah
and he goes look at this look and it
looked straight up straight up the gut
of my I've seen this guy [ __ ] wrong no
the other girl was in the room with him
who was he was so skinny
it was like Auschwitz but yeah I mean he
she was cute I thought no she was ugly
she was young right now I probably been
do it cuz she was 22 23 but like then it
was like kind of grody yeah and then so
we did that yeah and then then you're
like and your rule was hey here's the
deal
we're going now we're gonna do spots if
either one of us and he needed to get
pills in Tijuana
everybody goes if either one of us get
laid we're not gonna get hookers but if
we do get laid no hookers it was like
yeah sure and then I did get laid and
you were like hookers anyway I went down
you know let I do it a lot
I just want to say that the truth is I
think that was the one the last time I
ever went down there I was I've only
been there two times and that was one of
them yeah it's fun it's so I know what
I'm saying like just to have you know
just to go across the border and just
[ __ ] some like hooker dude awful Street
burritos yeah I feel like a lot of girls
would really have fun with that type of
experience no but it's just not for them
also with the pills and stuff makes it
to get used to that extra danger because
you have to take all the like tin foil
off of the pill jars yeah because you
have to stuff it with a lot of cotton so
it doesn't matter at all
you have the taper to your body and walk
across so not only you like so we got a
tile he bought some of your pills you
know those little tunnel pill bottles
that are about the size of like like
this like two inches high yeah so
Bobby's like
the [ __ ] 300 pill bottle it's my pill
Z button fill that up and it was [ __ ]
he was like the size of this water
bottle yeah yeah
tape it to my body and in and you have
to like balance yourself when you're
walking across stuff like the metal
detectors because there's dogs she's
right and there's like Border Patrol the
whole thing and you're trying to nut
that shake and I didn't you know why
because I'm [ __ ] agile from the
Ocean's eleven that'll Asian guy oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay I'm fat now I wasn't
fat then you weren't thin I know but
look what I look like now yeah now
you're gross yeah yeah yeah I look weird
now huh you look different for sure
right
I look tell him about your plants to get
beard implants yeah I'm gonna get beard
implants beard yeah whatever
what I've never heard of that why I know
and I'm gonna do it they take it from
your head and just pull I should get
some cobble hunka pool oh yeah you know
about some couple oh yeah from watching
your act oh yeah yeah yeah you you get
your eyes eyelid yeah yeah you [ __ ]
remember so many [ __ ] things I didn't
know what I said any of those that I was
mean I met that well I think we you
stabbed yourself because you're
dishonest yeah that's Japanese and
that's Harry Caray right yeah sorry
Sango cool is that so and with a nice
accent too yeah yeah and then what
happened was and we're friends we're
BFFs that was a great trip and then yeah
right again and there's a photo if you
go to the main room right now there's
still a photo of me nari on the top
corner in one of those smaller rooms
yeah we took our Hollywood Boulevard is
one of those like like photo booths yeah
did was fake drawing so it looks like
it's drawn yeah we took that right after
we saw this black dude running down the
street with two boxes of sneakers like
running down the street words like it
took him like 30 seconds to get to us
yeah yeah man you got ready behind it
like how you stopped used to I mean
Bobby just watched him run right past us
and like wow did nothing nothing
also Hollywood Boulevard then is not
what it's like now
I mean when I used to drive from high
school up to Hollywood Boulevard you
would have like women just with their
titties out like processed it was really
really grimy and scary
[Music]